[Music]
are the state coronavirus shutdowns
taking away our personal freedoms
joining me to discuss that a more
political commentator and author of
don't burn this book which Dave Rubin
just told me has made the New York Times
bestsellers list way to go Dave all
right listen to me
so you already good as Americans our
independent we're freedom loving and the
locking us up okay what with it whether
it's a Shelly Luther or the rest of us
what are we going to do to get out of
this yeah well first off let me just say
that Shelly Luther is a true American
Hero and every American should believe
that regardless of their political
persuasion I mean the woman wants to put
food on her kid's table it's a beautiful
thing I'm here in California I live in
Los Angeles so I have a progressive
governor in Gavin Newsom I've got a
progressive mayor in Eric Garcetti who's
literally telling me to go out and
snitch on my neighbor's and maybe I'm
gonna get a reward Gavin Newsom of
course who's the governor he was the one
that was the mayor of San Francisco and
he basically ruined that city and you
know they're they're telling us that we
can't go to the beach well here in SoCal
it's about 85 and perfect today and I
did get a little color in my backyard
but it's like how about you tell us
something mature tell us we have to go
to the beach at half capacity and maybe
have a car with a space between another
car and you can only go in group support
give us something that will make us feel
like mature adults as you're supposed to
do as government officials don't just
say you can't go to the beach just
because we say it as if as if what they
say is true just because they worded it
and I think that's the problem with
progressive no generally they think that
because they say something it's
inherently true well you know what's
amazing about New York we just found out
this week that some incredible number of
people who were staying at home
sheltering in at home it's like 66
percent it may be even higher than that
are coming up with a coronavirus so stay
at home you get the virus at least hunt
them get a tan you know little vitamin D
would help them out don't you think a
little vitamin D would help them out and
I'll tell you this look my family I come
from New York I was born in Brooklyn I
grew up in Long Island I lived in
Manhattan most of my life most of my
family lives in New York my sister and
her family you know the weather is good
I thought we had a beach now we don't
have it I'm not sure what I'm doing here
Texas is looking pretty good these days
but I will tell you this my my sister
and her family and two kids just moved
out of New York City this week because
people people want to be free your intro
is exactly right Americans love Liberty
love freedom and by the way we're
willing to take a little risk to be free
nobody's saying just get out there and
do whatever you want and crowd
everything people are saying hey we got
to get back to our lives we're not
hamsters in a cage and you got to let us
take a little risk so we can decide what
the threshold is for our lives as
opposed to just be getting it as an
edict you know from somebody up in
Sacramento in my case yeah well and the
shame of it all is you know we've all
been we've all been trained to wash our
hands and keep our hands away from our
face that you know you would think they
would figure well they've got some of it
right you know maybe we can let them out
a little bit but anyway Dave Rubin I
want to congratulate you on hitting the
New York Times bestsellers list
don't burn this book and we look forward
to having you on again if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell